growing up i always enjoyed those
claymation christmas specials you know
like santa claus is
coming to town and rudolph the red-nosed
reindeer i really love that as well
now that i have my own tv show i finally
had the opportunity
to produce my own so folks without any
further ado i present
to you now our very own late night
claymation
christmas special
[Music]
well andy it finally feels like
christmas do you think santa's gonna
come this year
santa claus there's no such thing as
santa claus
but you gotta believe conan
hey what's that ah i hear nothing
merry christmas ow
wow merry christmas
yay it's santa claus oh my god i don't
believe it
it's true wow
i heard someone doesn't believe in santa
claus i'm sorry santa
you should be sorry god i've been this
motor city rocket slater let's have a
motor city merry christmas come on all
right
[Applause]
come on merry christmas gonna rock and
[Music]
rock
i can roll it over one time 360 degrees
goodbye new york city however
we got to deliver all the prisons all
across the land all right
[Applause]
[Music]
oh the boys and girls
hey now that we're in space let's
reflect on the true meaning of christmas
like spending time with your friends and
family
yeah and joy to the world and peace
on earth and rock and roll
we really captured christmas there i
think we did that the morning we got
back from chicago
that took us 40 minutes to make that
wasn't an easy 40 minutes either all
right folks we'll take a break when we
come back
nora dunn is with us so stick around